[Музика]
добре, хлопці, ласкаво просимо назад, ми продовжуємо
обговорювати роботу та кар'єру сьогодні
ми збираємося обговорити дуже важливі
навички. Я знаю, що
у вашому житті є багато навичок, наприклад, ви знаєте
англійську, це  вміння або ви можете кататися на
сноуборді та сноуборді, це також
навичка, або ви можете малювати, писати або читати
, це також вміння рахувати - це навик
це важкі навички, але сьогодні
ми поговоримо про м'які навички м'які
навички необхідні  Хороший
фахівець, щоб бути хорошим співробітником, вам
потрібно володіти цими навичками, тому давайте
подивимося на цю діаграму, де ви можете побачити
такі навички, як управління часом або
спритність, смирення та терпіння,
а потім – навички міжособистісного спілкування та
ведення змін робочої етики, комунікації,
і якщо ви  у вас є всі ці навички у
вашій особистості, вони відповідають один одному,
як пазл, і ви стаєте кращим
співробітником, тому сьогодні ми збираємося
обговорити необхідність їх навичок у вашій
майбутній кар’єрі, давайте подивимося, щоб
підготуватися до  ми отримаємо більше нового
словникового запасу, тож завдання полягає в тому, щоб заповнити
прогалини правильною фразою з
коробки, подивіться на місце ящика, щоб
спочатку аналізувати інформацію, потім
добре спілкуватися, а потім
добре розв’язувати проблеми для прийняття рішень
у 21 столітті  і епоха технологій,
вам потрібно гортати весь текст,
щоб отримати загальне уявлення про нього, ви
повинні подумати, куди слід поставити дієслово або
де слід поставити іменник, і насправді
це буде підказкою для вас, тому вперше,
коли ви гортаєте  через весь текст це
означає, що ви швидко переглядаєте весь
текст, щоб отримати загальну ідею, а
потім намагаєтеся заповнити прогалини, тоді ми
зможемо перевірити ваші відповіді добре, хлопці,
давайте подивимося відповіді тут,
давайте прочитаємо текст  і вставте
правильні варіанти Я почну читати ми
живемо в 21 столітті деякі
люди називають це століттям технологій, нам
потрібно навчитися таким навичкам, як
вирішення проблем, і ми повинні вміти
добре спілкуватися з іншими людьми
навколо  d Світові роботодавці
шукають людей, які добре аналізують інформацію
людей, які вміють розпізнавати,
де інформація достовірна чи ні, їм
також подобаються люди, які вміють приймати
рішення, не звертаючись за допомогою, хлопці, чи
можете ви сказати мені, які soft skills
згадуються в  цей текст я бачу, як
вирішувати проблеми та добре приймати
рішення
та аналізувати інформацію та
комунікацію, тому це ті м’які
навички, яких їм не навчають в
університетах, їх не навчають у
школах, їх навчає життя, або ми
можемо добре розвинути навички  можливо, це
теж круто, давайте продовжимо, зараз ми збираємося
знову прочитати текст про soft skills, які
вам знадобляться для вашої майбутньої роботи,
завдання те саме, ви знаєте, це
починається досить добре, правда чи неправда,
давайте переглянемо твердження, тому
перше  навичкам 21 століття
не навчають у школах у Великобританії, це
твердження вірне чи помилкове, просто здогадайтесь,
тоді роботодавці люблять, щоб працівники
проявляли уяву, можливо, так, можливо  ні, тоді
роботодавці хочуть, щоб працівники добре подумали
про можливі проблеми для мене, це
безумовно хороший вибір, якщо працівник
може побачити можливі проблеми та вирішити
їх, але, хлопці, ви повинні пам'ятати, що
ці твердження мають бути правдивими чи хибними, а
не відповідно до ваших загальних даних
знання, але відповідно до тексту
номер для роботодавців, як працівники, бути
оригінальними при вирішенні проблем може бути
номером 5 майбутнім працівникам потрібно буде
вміти писати стисло, тобто
коротко, потім люди
менше спілкуються один з одним у 21 столітті чи
це правда робити  вони менше спілкуються, ми
побачимо, що роботодавці вважають, що корисно
знати багато інформації про
знаменитостей, чому я маю знати про Леді
Гагу чи Мадонну, який сенс у
цьому номер 8 роботодавці не хочуть, щоб працівники
приймали рішення, не запитуючи про
це  Я насправді хочу, щоб мій працівник приходив
щоразу, коли йому або їй потрібно
прийняти рішення, добре, хлопці, і знову ви
пам'ятаєте, що я робив з вами минулого разу
так, будь ласка, позначте
речення, які я позначив як істинні чи
хибні, але чи пам’ятаєте ви,
що минулого разу я був дійсно злим, цього разу я дійсно
маю на увазі, що є помилки, тому подивіться на
цей слайд і знайдіть мої помилки
після прочитання курсу  А тепер,
будь ласка, слідкуйте за мною, читаючи, чи
маєте ви навички, необхідні для роботи в 21-му столітті,
нам потрібно розвивати всі
види навичок, щоб вижити в 21-му столітті,
наприклад, навички ІКТ та
знання цифрового світу чітко викладаються
в школах у  Велика Британія ось 5 менш
очевидних
навичок, про які ви можете подумати. Це такі навички, про які
роботодавці можуть задати вам
на співбесіді, тому варто
подумати про те, наскільки ви хороші в цих
сферах, які ваші сильні та
слабкі сторони  уява в епоху
технологій, в яку ми живемо зараз,
уже недостатньо продовжувати виробляти ті
самі продукти, роботодавцям потрібні люди, які
можуть уявити нові підходи та нові ідеї, які
думають про  якщо об’єкт або гаджет, який ви
використовуєте щодня, як його можна покращити, чи
можете ви подумати про три покращення.
Роботодавці, які вирішують проблеми, будуть цінувати
працівників, які здатні побачити проблеми
до того, як вони виникнуть, і придумати
творчі рішення, уявіть, що ви
організуєте кінець  термін соціальний захід
у школі подумайте про деякі проблеми, з якими
ви могли б зіткнутися, чи можете ви придумати якесь
рішення
комунікативні навички працівники
повинні бути хорошими комунікаторами, вони
повинні вміти вести переговори та обговорювати ключові
питання, а також писати чітко,
не використовуючи зайвих  багато слів думають, як
люди спілкуються один з одним
у 21 столітті критичного аналізу
роботодавці хочуть, щоб працівники могли
розпізнати різницю між
інформацією, якій можна повірити, та
неправдивою інформацією, думають, використовують Інтернет,
щоб дізнатися три факти про
знаменитість або відомого  Чи можете ви
перевірити інформацію, перевіривши інші
веб-сайти
, на яких збільшується кількість окремих працівників, які приймають рішення
відповідальність важливо
вміти оцінювати ситуацію та бути
впевненим у прийнятті рішення, подумайте,
які три речі ви могли б зробити, щоб бути
здоровішим.
тоді просто зробіть це
добре, хлопці, тому ми читаємо текст, і тут я
знову показую ці твердження
правда/неправда, тепер давайте перевіримо їх, щоб ви
бачили мої відповіді, ось вони, давайте перевіримо,
скільки помилок я зробив, тому перша помилка,
так, це  Чи це неправда,
що навичкам 21 століття не викладають
у школах Великобританії, але вони
навчаються, але не дуже високою швидкістю.
як працівники, щоб бути оригінальними, вирішуючи
проблеми, майбутні працівники повинні
вміти писати коротко, щоб писати
коротко, люди менше спілкуються один з
одним у 21 столітті це
неправда, ми спілкуємося  багато, але ми багато
спілкуємося, використовуючи інші засоби
комунікації з текстом, і
тому ми повинні бути дуже лаконічними,
справді короткими,
тоді роботодавці вважають, що
корисно знати багато інформації
про знаменитостей твердження є неправдивим
роботодавці вважають, що  вам потрібно
знати різницю між правдивою інформацією
та неправдивою інформацією, і останнє
речення роботодавці не хочуть, щоб працівники
приймали рішення, не питаючи їх добре,
звичайно, вони хочуть, щоб
ми самі приймали рішення, і твердження є
хибним, тому давайте продовжимо зараз  перевірити своє
розуміння за допомогою словникового запасу-заповнити прогалини
подивіться у вас є зробити значення
диференціювати розвивати обговорювати навчати та
розв’язувати вам не потрібно змінювати форму,
ви повинні заповнити речення
цими словами, давайте подивимося на
перше  одна школа і коледж Великобританії
навичок ІКТ то що б ви вставили, я думаю, що
це має бути навчити ще раз усе
речення Школи та коледжі Великобританії навчають
навичкам ІКТ ІКТ mea  російські інформаційно-
комунікаційні технології потім приходять
роботодавці люди з ідеями для нових
підходів роботодавці цінують людей з
ідеями для нових підходів цінувати означає
цінувати і бути вдячними за це,
потім йдуть роботодавці, як працівники, які
можуть проблеми що ми робимо з проблемами
ми вирішуємо проблеми, які потрібно працівникам
вміти працювати разом зі своєю командою, щоб робити
те, що зі своєю роботою обговорювати
неможливо нічого не обговорювати з
вашою командою, і має бути хороша
команда і хороша робота, тоді працівники
повинні мати свої навички письма, я думаю, щоб
розвивати їх письмові навички  навички
наступний важливо, щоб працівники могли
розрізняти правду та брехню,
можна побачити різницю між правдою та
брехнею працівники у 21 столітті більше
відповідальності, тому ми маємо
більше відповідальності, це правда, сьогодні ми
маємо більше відповідальності, ніж наші
батьки  щоб наступний
роботодавець любив своїх працівників приймати
рішення, і ми, в основному, повинні
прийняти рішення  cisions щодня добре, хлопці, тож
перегляньте речення ще раз, і
якщо ви не знаєте жодного зі слів,
запишіть їх, а потім додайте їх у свій
Quizlet. Добре, давайте продовжимо зараз знову,
ви готові до граматичної закуски сьогодні,
ми»  я збираюся переглянути два часи,
перший – минулий тривалий час,
тому ви повинні пам’ятати, що ми формуємо його
за допомогою слів і дієслова плюс
форми дієслова, а ключові слова – while, а
коли добре, тоді simple past were past
simple це  коротка дія, і він
використовується з, наприклад, коли і він
перериває тривалішу дію подивіться я
йшов, коли він кричав на мене я
йшов, це довгий процес, а потім
він кричав на мене, він перервав більше
дії або вона складала папери
коли вона порізала палець порізала палець -
це коротка дія, і вона
складала його вони мили свою
машину вони були в процесі довгої дії
мили машину, коли кіт стрибнув на
нього, тому кіт перервав цю дію,
давайте подивимося  якщо вживається разом з while це
означає, що це означає, що щось
відбувалося під час розмови, вона
кричала на мене, коли я йшов, коли
вона складала папір, вона порізала
палець, щоб ви могли використовувати Antoine і while,
і ви повинні пам'ятати, що  минуле
продовжується - це довга дія, давайте
рухатися далі дитина спала, поки
мама готувала занадто довгі
дії, що відбувалися одночасно
дитина спала і мама
готувала наступне, я був за кермом, поки
мама розмовляла зі мною я керував автомобілем
і водночас у цей самий момент
моя мама говорила зі мною тут, у нас є
тривалі дії та тривалі дії, давайте
продовжимо, так що подивіться, ви можете побачити
зображення
потрібно помістити їх у пропуски, тож давайте
подивимося, що перше дієслово kir then comes
cross drive full asleep fly отримайте кільце
бігайте почати та ходити вони закреслені,
тому що вони вже вживаються, а потім
вивчайте та працюйте давайте та  подивіться на
перше речення перше зображення, коли вони
йшли вулицею, коли
почався дощ, вони були в процесі,
а потім інша дія перервала
їх добре, подивіться хвилинку на ці
речення, спробуйте заповнити прогалини, а
потім ми  перевіримо їхні відповіді,
хлопці, давайте перевіримо їхні відповіді, тому
вдруге, коли задзвонив телефон, коли вона
вболівала за свою дитину, вона допомагала
своїй дитині, а потім задзвонив телефон, він
перервав дію, потім прийшов, коли
вона працювала,
їй подзвонили  працювала вона була справді зайнята,
вона щось робила, а потім
задзвонив телефон і перервав її
довгу дію вона працювала коротку
дію телефон задзвонив наступний,
поки він їхав, він знову вдавився в
дерево довгий хід, він їхав
і  бум він врізався в дерево її
перервало це дерево наступне він
заснув, поки добре вчився
дуже поширена ситуація зі студентами, яких
ти навчаєшся пізно ввечері і уявляєш
ти вчився, а потім в одну мить ти
заснув і востаннє птах пролетіла
над її головою
ну вона бігала по пляжу,
птах не літала з нею всю дорогу,
вона просто пролетіла над її головою, тому вона
бігла  дія, і птах пролетів,
є коротким, добре, тому перше
запитання чи готові ви до цієї вікторини,
давайте подивимося, коли ви відкриєте двері, а потім
ви здивувались, що б ви
вибрали, відкриваємо,
ми відкриваємо, чи відкриваємо вам
виберіть, і він відкритий так, це
короткі дії, ви відкриваєте двері, і ви
були здивовані.
підряд давайте подивимося, що у
нас тут відрижка була оплачена
і біль хм,
я думаю, що я точно знаю, що
останній біль неправильний, ви не можете
використовувати форму ing без будь-яких допоміжних дієслів
добре, тому зосередьтесь на першому  три
і відповідь платна установка  ht минулого понеділка
я оплатив свої рахунки і залишив
добре наступного. Я хочу, щоб тарілку було розчавлено,
щоб тарілка була подрібнена, можливо, я був у
процесі чогось давайте подивимося, що ми
тут готуємо, точно не пам'ятаю, ви
не можете використовувати форму без будь-яких  допоміжні
дієслова then comes we're cooked cooked
and was cooking I can't be were cooking
not у цьому випадку I та B неправильні,
тож давайте виберемо між C і D готові
вибрати один два три, і відповідь
буде готувати це правильно  довга дія була
перервана з цією табличкою га
наступний номер чотири ми бігли на
станцію саме тоді, коли потяг,
тож ми бігали і що
робив потяг, хлопці, я дав вам натяк, що
ми їдемо, коханий, жити
знову д  і a, безперечно, не ті
речення, які нам потрібні, ви не можете сказати, що живете,
і ви не можете сказати, що потяг, робота – це
один, так що це має бути, був атлас добре готовий
один два
три відповідь: жили, ми бігали,
і ми були так, як  поїзд просто
зникав вер  у нещасній ситуації
наступна з шостої до шостої п'ятнадцяти I
малюю, коли я гуляв я
гуляв у цей час і, можливо, занадто
довгі дії переглядати відповіді
ще раз відповідь B неправильна, тому що
ви не можете сказати в цьому  випадок я працюю і
знову D точно не добре, хлопці, будь ласка
, знайте, що вам потрібні допоміжні дієслова okay,
тому 1 2 3 готові до відповіді, і так,
я фотографував з 6:00 до 6:15
я фотографував, коли
гуляв  але добре, давайте
ще п'ять раз добре, наступний
закінчився минулого тижня вони боляче від Монті до
п'ятниці за минулий тиждень означає протягом
останнього тижня протягом усього останнього тижня, тож що
б ви використали один два три, і
відповідь була  працювали протягом
останнього тижня вони наполегливо працювали з
понеділка по п'ятницю ми хочемо показати тривалу
дію, і ми отримали це протягом останнього
тижня не тільки минулого тижня, але
протягом останнього тижня наступного привіт вам,
ваші зуби, коли раптом вона  прийшов
у ванну просто імагі  не ситуація,
яку ви просто робите, так, а
потім вона заходить у вашу ванну, добре,
так що це за дія, це довго
чи коротко, подивіться під чищенням
не все гаразд, ви пам’ятаєте чому, і тоді з тобою
точно не все гаразд  тож оберіть
між а та D один два три,
відповідь однозначно D добре номер 8, будь ласка,
коли вони по дорозі знайшли O
ще раз уявіть ситуацію, що ви
гуляєте, ви йдете, і ви бачите або
бачите о, можливо, на  дерево або, можливо, на
землі, я не знав, так що знову ви
в процесі, і що це за дія, це
довга дія і правильна відповідь знову
ось гуляли добре ще двоє на
номер 9 він не зробив домашнє завдання  він
спав всю ніч, тому він спав
цілу ніч так, він спав всю ніч,
і тому він не зробив домашнє завдання,
а потім наступне останнє о 9:00
Шон читав, поки Саманта, так
що вона робила, це натяк  вона робила
покупки надто тривалі дії, що відбувалися
одночасно
Шон йшов дощ, а Саманта ходила по
магазинах, хлопці, всі готові до виконання
домашнього завдання, цього разу це домашнє завдання буде
онлайн, і якщо ви дивитеся на нас на
YouTube, ви отримаєте ці посилання
під відео, тож, будь ласка, дотримуйтесь
їх і виконайте граматику  завдання на минуле
просте та безперервне минуле, ви просто
клацніть це посилання, а потім
будуть деякі вправи, тому вам доведеться
ввести слова, а потім натиснути Enter або
надіслати свої відповіді, і якщо ваші відповіді
виділені жирним шрифтом, це означає, що вони
правильно, ви можете виконувати ці вправи
скільки завгодно разів, я
безумовно рекомендую вам скористатися цим
веб-сайтом, щоб покращити свої граматичні навички,
ним дуже легко орієнтуватися, і
це дуже корисно добре, хлопці, слідкуйте за оновленнями
, насолоджуйтеся своїми днями в школі та
будьте  повернутися до наступного уроку, до побачення
[Музика].